is one of the deadliest terror groups in
the world in the last year alone Boko
Haram has killed nearly 7,000 people in
attacks across Nigeria even striking the
capital Abuja but that was all supposed
to be over by the end of this month at
least that's what Nigeria's new
government promised earlier this year
but speaking to DW the country's
Minister of Information put the pledge
into perspective actually means that
child who have any attack at all this
lone wolf Suzanne Bombay did not end
overnight to taper off after some time
the Army has managed to take back much
of the territory that had been under the
control of Boko Haram but hundreds of
thousands of Nigerians are still too
afraid to return home political analyst
Jeeva Ibrahim has always doubted a
deadline could be set for defeating the
terror group for a huge insurgency like
this the presidential intervene have
given such a definitive deadline because
as of the time that deadline was given
we did not know the exact strength of
the insurgents for many Nigerians there
is a constant worry of suicide bombings
Boko Haram often seeks to exploit the
violence in its propaganda videos
Nigeria's Minister of Information says
the country needs more support from
Western countries we'll have the clips
on ground to tell in terms of if we're
talking about a numerical figure I don't
have enough troops on Graham but what we
need is probably no more information
better trainee and
probably they need to know more
equipment and of course we need
resources because it's really expensive
to sustain this war but security experts
say counterterrorism operations have to
include better regional cooperation the
volkl Haram militants driven out of
their strongholds in Nigeria are now
thought to have fled to other West
African countries